turning now to a new list of the best
places to live
in the country u.s news and world report
ranks 150 of the most populated
metropolitan areas
across the country based on
affordability job prospects
and desirability this year here are the
winners get ready fifth
best place to live is austin texas
at number four fayetteville arkansas
in third place is huntsville alabama
wow number two raleigh and durham north
carolina
drum roll please number one
new york city no it's boulder colorado
u.s news and world reports real estate
editor devin thorsby joins us now to
break down the rankings devin good
morning welcome thanks for being here
good morning so boulder colorado tops
the list for the second year in a row
why is it up there at the very top
boulder uh
has kind of a natural ability to attract
a lot of people who want to move to the
area so it's definitely one of the most
desirable place
desirable places to live in the us it's
actually tied for tenth in terms of
desirability
with new york city which i find to be an
interesting juxtaposition just because
they are
so different but also boulder's uh job
market is extremely strong
and despite the fact that the entire
country
experienced skyrocketing unemployment
throughout 2020
boulder's market was able to remain
relatively stable and keep unemployment
rates
pretty low compared to the rest of the
country which ended up
really helping it uh in in best places
to live keeping it to the top
on top of that it's just one of those
places people love the idea of being
able to get outdoors and things like
that
um easy access to those things and i
think during the pandemic that's even
been amplified more and so people are
eyeing boulder as a
an ideal place to move you mentioned
that new york city ranks tenth
and desirability uh why don't big cities
like new york la or chicago
rank higher on this overall list yes um
one thing that we look at and it's
definitely an important aspect that a
lot of people consider when they're
moving to a new metro area is
affordability and the cost of living
and these biggest cities in the country
and their surrounding metro areas
are unfortunately for a lot of people
not that easy to afford
a lot of people's paychecks have to go
toward housing costs whether that's
mortgage payments rent property taxes
utilities
things like that and so the median
household income
in a lot of cases doesn't match up with
the median cost of living there
i love austin texas devin looks like
your light just went out on you but i
look there you go
i i love austin texas so i'm not
surprised that austin made the list
but do the five cities that are in the
top five do they have anything in common
um a lot of them offer um kind of a
smaller major metro uh setting so
boulder raleigh and durham huntsville
fayetteville austin
uh they certainly offer kind of the the
amenities of a big city that people want
to see definitely
when it's not pandemic times
entertainment will come to the area
lots of conferences and things but it
also has
sprawling suburbs and areas that
allow people to get outdoors they don't
necessarily feel so packed in
and i think that's definitely something
that we've seen as a result of the
pandemic partially from
desirability but also people are looking
to
to move to those places as well and
devin on that note you know what changes
and trends have you seen
because of the pandemic it looks like
about one third of americans said the
pandemic changed
their preferences for where to live yes
uh it doesn't directly this survey that
we did doesn't directly impact the best
places to live
uh rankings but we wanted to look at
kind of
and be able to estimate what's going to
happen in the future and uh so we
surveyed
u.s residents and a third of americans
say that the pandemic has changed
uh their opinion about where they live
and 11
say that they have relocated or planned
to relocate as a result of the pandemic
um 57 of those people
are looking to move to a less dense area
than where they live now
of course 25 percent there's still
people that love the idea of city living
25
are hoping to move to a more densely pop
populated area
um and i think that that's reflected
when we see
uh the desirability survey in the best
places to live and down the line when we
look at
our long-term net migration i think
we'll see
some big differences in a couple of
years uh as a result of the pandemic
i'm trying to figure out devin how you
guys determine desirability when you
have all of
these different cities yes uh
desirability is something especially
because it's
the opportunity to kind of gut check
what people think of metro areas
and so we conduct a survey every year um
asking
thousands of people across the country
just where they prefer to live given the
choice we don't necessarily
ask why because i know those reasons
that people give can be very subjective
it can be
about the job market it could simply be
that they want to be by the beach
and so our desirability survey is
conducted
we conducted through surveymonkey and
this year we had a little over 3 600
respondents and of course you always see
lots of beach cities lots of
florida metro areas reaching the top of
desirability
but you also see the the austins the
boulders
um the new york cities as well all right
devin thoresby thank you so much for
joining us before you
before you came on you should know we
all agreed you have got one of the
coolest names
yes i just assumed you were going to be
british devin thoresby
that's such a nice name i'm going to add
you to the list of cool names you and
lilia luciano
are on that i love those names thank you
devin thank you